ben roethlisberger steelers quarterback
placed on the covet 19 reserve list
because he sat next to vance mcdonald on
the flight back from dallas on sunday
mcdonald another one of these guys
falling into that donut hole game day
testing sample collected in the morning
result comes back positive anyone in
close contact with him goes on to the
covet 19 reserve list for five days
roethlisberger and three others must
isolate for five days and test negative
before returning
so what that means is just like matthew
stafford last week ben roethlisberger is
going to be
unprepared from a practice standpoint to
face the bengals on sunday now he may
not have practiced very much anyway he
never practices on wednesday shireen but
still he is going to have to participate
in video conferences only as they get
ready for a bengals team that's had two
weeks to prepare
and that frankly is good enough to beat
the steelers because the steelers have
only had one convincing win all season
long
yeah mike and you said he might not
practice that's what's going to be my
point you know he has the two knee
injuries and so i what kind of
what kind of rehab is he doing right now
is he having to do this at home is he
getting to go to the facility to do this
right he's not allowed at the facility
right so he's having to do this rehab on
his own with his niece i assume
great point he's gotta isolate for five
days i mean he's gotta isolate he's
gotta isolate for five days he's
potentially going to infect whoever
would come to his house and work on the
knees there so that's a potential
problem as it relates to rehab and and
maybe it will be they they send him all
the equipment he needs and he's going to
be doing his own physical therapy from
from home or you know if his spouse can
be shown what needs to be done again
depending upon what they're doing to
address these knee injuries that becomes
a complicating factor as well that's a
good point here's mike tomlin coach of
the steelers talking about ben
roethlisberger missing time this week
you know i'm not overly concerned about
it this guy's been doing his job for 17
years
he's got snap experience that he can
call upon um we're still going to work
extremely hard virtually um to prepare
um a lot of his work is above the neck
anyway um in terms of preparation i have
very little concern about it to be quite
honest with you
and look i i don't expect my tama to say
anything else he's not going to make any
excuses he's not going to say well we
may as well just not even play the game
this weekend they deal with it whether
it's injuries whether it's
unavailability due to covet this is
something the steelers haven't had to
deal with all year long shireen it just
started recently
and and i think it's indicative of the
reality that no matter what a team does
to try to avoid it
there's still too many people who go
out into the community every night and
as the numbers go up in our communities
in the communities where the nfl teams
are located
you're going to have people show up for
work who are positive for the virus and
they're going to potentially spread it
before anyone knows they have it so
anything other than a home market bubble
this is just part of the reality of the
next eight weeks in the nfl and we can
only hope they hold it together and hope
they'll have a home market bubble or
something closely equivalent to it by
the time the post season rolls around
and ben roethlisberger before the season
started mike said he was going to do all
the the right things not have anybody
over at his house no visitors no friends
no family nobody to come to the house he
was going to homeschool his kids he's
going to basically isolate at home which
now he's been around vance mcdonald who
tested positive who he was seen talking
on the sidelines too without a mask and
then sat next to him on the plane and so
here we are with ben roethlisberger
possibly maybe getting covered himself
uh we'll see hopefully he doesn't and he
can return and play this weekend and and
get back out there but it does tell you
that you can be as safe as possible and
you still just never know you may be
around someone who has covered 19 and i
think it's a lesson for all of us right
i mean we see the cases going up six
straight days of 100 000 cases in this
country and you just you unless you just
isolate your house you just can't be 100
sure that you're not going to be around
somebody who has coveted 19.
and i i
i think that that's a critical point
because
the nfl says
that
they're going to assume that everyone
who walks through the door has it
we don't see on the sidelines
during games
behavior that would suggest
that the players and the coaches are
making that assumption if anything
they're assuming everyone's clean i mean
i was watching the jets game last night
and you've got dow loggins the offensive
coordinator with ma i mean why even have
a mask on if it's basically going to be
something to catch the food that falls
from your mouth right why the hell even
have the thing on and you've got guys
sitting elbow to elbow on the bench one
has a mask on one doesn't and i i i feel
like most of the guys on the sidelines
when they wear masks they don't have
their noses covered
which is asinine it's just flat out
asinine what's the point if you don't
cover your nose your nose is one of the
main entry points of the virus it's more
important to have it over your nose and
your mouth so my point is i feel like
they think that once it's time to go out
onto the sidelines
they've got some safe harbor
that they they don't have to worry about
that's why they have to worry about it
the most shireen and we're finding that
out and they have to get that message
through to the players and the coaches
and i just feel like they can't they
can't deal with that
while they're worrying about trying to
win a football game maybe they'll get
there by the end of the season maybe
they won't we'll see
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports